there's basically no one who wanted to  know about prize and physics at least or  even economics died with a net worth  substantially greater than you know his  unfortunately not unfortunately but just  the fact that most of the Nobel Prize  winners are male only two living female  Nobel Prize winners in physics but but  anyway none of them died Einstein  included Charlie Townes invented the  laser and uh you know that Shockley  invented the transistor they died  basically with less you know net worth  than their Nobel prizes now obviously  when I asked them and I asked out your  alma mater Guido imbens at Stanford who  won the Nobel prize in economics last  year I sent me you know why why aren't  all these Nobel laureates an economics  billionaire multi-billionaires